well the thing with the earth is that we
know a lot about
the surface of it right that's where we
live
if you were to shrink the earth down to
about the size of an apple
the crust portion would be about as
thick as the skin
and we have never gone deep enough to do
more than even just scratch the surface
of that skin
[Music]
so pete yes it feels like it's been a
while since
uh the craze that is sweeping the nation
in the world
the what if discuss trivia challenge oh
we haven't had
an episode of that in a while where we
put you on the hot seat
and test your knowledge of
in this case deep deeply mysterious
scientific matters
uh how deep do you believe
it the earth is to the core to the core
so not
the mantle no not that yeah it's good
point because you could be talking the
crust
can we talk on the mantel right to the
core uh i'm going to take a guess in
miles
yeah i'm going to say 5 000 miles well
actually it is in the area code but
it is and that's actually a pretty good
guess it's actually uh
6 000 kilometers 63
give or take so knowing that
what is the deepest that you believe we
the humans have gone or drilled
this one uh your pop quiz you can't
stump me on this one because this is
actually one of our more popular what
ifs
uh at under known and it was uh what if
you dug the deepest hole in the world
or what if you fell down the deepest
hole in the world it was the cola super
deep borehole that is correct right 12
kilometers 12 kilometers which before i
knew
how deep the actual earth was i was like
12 kilometers
it's got to be that's crazy and then
when you find out
that it's about 6 300 kilometers to the
core
and you sort of do some quick math you
realize we're not even
it's like point two percent oh yeah
we've barely scratched the surface if
the earth is like this we've only dug
like that
that deep so if anyone and and to that
point
i mean we've explored space and we
continue to explore space we continue to
talk about space
but there's obviously a lot to
better understand about the planet that
we live on currently
and there's not a lot of people who
would probably have a good guess as to
what might happen if we explored the
deepest parts of the earth but again
somebody that will a good friend of the
show oh yeah
host of angry planet and multiple other
shows in the science channel
joins us again today george kurunis
george how are you george
hey guys good to be here so it is
again as peter said we've kind of just
scratched the surface so
you have an explorer spirit peter
mentioned earlier how
you know how little we know let's say
about the inner earth
and we've only drilled 10 kilo or 12
kilometers deep
what do you believe and i mean not just
believe subjectively but what
your what do you and your colleagues in
the world of science and exploration
believe
we were we are going to find if we could
go deeper into the earth
well the thing with the earth is that we
know a lot about
the surface of it right that's where we
live
if you were to shrink the earth down to
about the size of an apple
the crust portion would be about as
thick as the skin
and we have never gone deep enough to do
more than even just scratch the surface
of that skin wow and
that really helps to sort of put things
in perspective most of
our planet that we live on that's been
here for over 4 billion years or so
we know nothing about or not nothing
about we can only
make educated guesses about we have no
ability to see
deep into the earth we can only measure
reflections from earthquakes and
hypothesize about what's going on down
there and we've learned a lot
we know basically what's going on down
there
the thing is we don't know the things
that we don't know
so there's all kinds of untold mysteries
yet to be discovered
in inner space yeah inner space uh the
exploration that's happened uh
digging into the earth was sort of
similar to the exploration of space
like uh sort of the cold war us versus
ussr
um give us a bit of background on that
history and and also
maybe what projects are going on in the
name of science that are looking to go
deeper
there's lots of cool stuff going on
underground uh
last year i was up in sudbury ontario
and i was two kilometers underground in
an active nickel mine and there there's
the neutrino observatory the snow lab
neutrino observatory down there i well i
went down that a few years ago george
actually for another thing what we were
doing there not
related with what if but it was i mean
talk about that elevator ride down two
kilometers
just getting to this lab is unbelievable
you have to go into an active mine
get dressed up with the mining helmets
the whole works you get into this
elevator that just
drops and drops and drops at such
incredible speeds
your ears are popping you get down there
and then you have to walk
through this dirty mine to get to
the lab and the lab is established as a
clean room
so you have to strip naked take a shower
you put on special clean clothes
and then you're allowed into the
facility and they study neutrinos coming
from the sun
they're looking for dark matter and dark
energy the stuff that makes up a lot of
the mass of the
universe that we don't really understand
all that well
so we can learn a lot about
the universe and outer space by going
into our
planet because that uh that those
two kilometers of rock helps to shield
the
sensors that are so incredibly sensitive
down there so every now and then a stray
neutrino will penetrate
through the earth and hit one of their
sensors you're in this technological
boom right now kind of what was like
what's going on in the cold war but
instead of trying to compete to
go to the moon or to build a better
submarine or something
where you know there's we're looking
outwards and
we might learn a lot more than we
thought we want to bring you a message
from our friends at netsuite.com
yeah if you're a business owner it
doesn't matter what type of business
necessarily i mean you could be
it could be flying people to the
stratosphere in a balloon balloon to the
stream
that's a business we're not going to
tell you how to run your business
because we're not business experts this
isn't a business show
but what we can tell you is you might be
making it harder on yourself than it
needs to be
yeah that's right so don't let
quickbooks and spreadsheets slow you
down anymore it's time to upgrade to
netsuite
stop paying for multiple systems that
don't give you the information you need
when you need it
like pete said it's 2021 get rid of the
old spreadsheets get rid of the old
school
outdated software right upgrade to
netsuite by oracle it's the world's
number one cloud business system yeah
netsuite gives you control and
visibility over your financials your
hr your inventory e-commerce and more
it's everything you need all in one
place instantaneously whether you're
doing
a million dollars or hundreds of
millions of dollars in revenue
save time and money with netsuite yeah
and it's tried and true it's not sort of
out of the blue there's already 20 000
people
on the netsuite cloud so you won't be
alone yeah it's not brand new it's been
around for a long time let netsuite show
you
how they'll benefit your business with a
free product tour at netsuite.com
what if schedule your free product tour
right now
at netsuite.com what if that's
netsuite.com
what if george you
talk about going deep and what we can
discover well
i had to go deep in preparing for this
show because this wasn't stuff that i
knew about a lot and of course
um you come across that we now believe
scientifically and
initially plea i was like george please
tell me i'm you know
misreading this that we believe that the
core of the earth
is 6 000 degrees celsius which wow that
sounds like a big number but then when
you
actually remind people that that's
hotter than the sun
i was like what like how could we
possibly exist
so george please enlighten us what is
going on there
that's the mind-blowing fact of this
whole discussion really is that the
center of the earth is as hot as the
surface of the sun
and it is so when when the earth formed
billions of years ago
all of this mass congealed together
thanks to gravity pulling it all
together into this sphere the heavier
elements like iron and nickel
went to the middle and it's all all of
it's under pressure and this tremendous
pressure creates a lot of heat so you've
got pressure
you've got friction the the core of the
earth is moving
so you've got that friction creating
heat and you also have the
uh decay of certain radioactive elements
creating heat as well
so all of these forces have combined
to create this ball of hidden energy
and then the crust where we live is the
layer of insulation
that is not only keeping us alive but
keeping that sphere cool and it's been
cooling for
billions of years wow yeah so
and here we are just you know living on
the surface of it
every now and then we see a volcano
erupt and we get we got a reminder
of this energy and heat that's beneath
our feet
but for the most part we take it
completely for granted and don't even
realize it
i can't even imagine like when if a bowl
of soup is too hot for me i set it aside
for five minutes
it's cooled down enough the earth is six
thousand degrees and it's been cooling
for
millions of years how hot must it have
been that's some serious uh
insulation we have two up here between
us and that
yeah so it's probably the world's best
insulin the world's best insulation
george we talked a little bit about how
we've explored the depths of the earth
and
uh you could say we've also explored
very little of the oceans most people
say about
90 of the ocean's floors or of the
oceans remain
undiscovered um mariana's mariana trench
is not necessarily
we know a little bit about that we've
been down and as as far as we know
it's the deepest ocean floor in the
world um
what else do we know or what else don't
we know
there's so much there's so much it's
hard to get to
right the bottom of the mariana trench
for example is about
36 000 feet down that's about as high as
a as a jet airliner flies
and i had the great pleasure of meeting
uh dawn walsh a few times and he was
on board the trieste with uh picard
the two of them went down to the bottom
in 1960
and just recently um we've had a few
more submarines go down there of course
james cameron
and victor viscova went down there
recently with his new submarine and a
chinese submarine just made it down
there for the very first time
so there's been a lot of of um attention
paid to the mariana trench
but there are other deep points in the
ocean that may not be quite as deep
that we still don't know anything about
we're discovering all kinds of stuff
below ground for example
a number of years ago i went to this
place in mexico called the nica crystal
cave
it took me two years to get permission
to go to this place
it's 900 feet underground in the
chihuahua desert
it was accidentally discovered in a
silver mine
they were drilling away and they broke
through into a chamber
that was about the size of a basketball
court
and it contained the biggest crystals
that anyone had ever seen
some of them are 10 meters long and
weigh 55
tons magical like tree trunks and it's
so
hot down there from that internal heat
from the from the earth
that we had to wear special suits filled
with ice packs
and a chilled air respirator so that we
could survive
inside the cave for more than a few
minutes at a time as soon as you step
foot inside that cave you start to die
because you're combining the heat of the
sahara desert
plus the humidity of the amazon jungle
it's almost 100
humidity so it's absolutely lethal
conditions
but it's so beautiful like superman's
fortress of solitude
and nobody knew it was there like a
geode
hidden underground that you can walk
around in
so who knows what else is down there wow
take that indiana jones wow that'd be so
cool that is
nuts man i i honestly like
i i you know if i had a time machine and
i could go back one of the parts
one part of me says you know look you
have no regrets but
the other part of me says man i wish i
would have been an archaeologist or
you know you know doing the type of work
that you do because again
there's just so much left to explore and
we know so little
and it's just nothing there's nothing
like that spirit of discovery and being
able to experience something like that
so much more to talk about uh can you
stick around
uh so we can take a deeper dive if you
will i knew you honey you were gonna say
that absolutely
there was no way we were getting through
this show without me saying that so
uh so george will be back uh with us on
the other side
but if people want to get the audio link
well uh
assuming they're not already listening
on audio they can just stay listening on
audio if they are
if you're watching us on youtube we'll
click that little link below
that'll take you to the extended audio
podcast and we'll hear more
about uh exploring the deepest parts of
the earth with angry planets george
kurunis
um we'll be right back after the break
but before we go george where can people
follow you and find your work
you can find me at furiousearth.com all
my links are there
and uh are there some wedding pictures
that the yeah i was going to say for for
those people who don't know
george correct me if i'm wrong because
it was on wikipedia but
did you honestly get married uh on the
on the
edge of a crater of an active volcano
actively
erupting exploding volcano on tana
island in vanuatu in the south pacific
back in 2006 the volcano was erupting
every few minutes with lava flying
hundreds of meters through the air while
we exchanged our vows
that is and i'm telling you right now
that would be very difficult to hire
a wedding photographer for that gig i'm
just going to go out on a limb and say
george is the coolest guy i've ever
certainly like i said 10 lifetimes right
here
for those of you who are ready to go
deeper click on the link come along for
the ride for those of you who can't
you're gonna miss out
but if you have to leave we'll see you
next time on what if discussed